let us dive
right in this week with the 2016
election
or as it's increasingly known america's
fucktastic circus to dismay
now the big news this week surrounded
donald trump a punchline
that is quickly becoming a nightmare but
like like if you said
take my wife please and then she was
actually kidnapped by isis
now this week revealed a somewhat
startling statistic
a new report from usa today found trump
and his businesses
have been involved in at least 3 500
lawsuits over three decades
3 500 lawsuits that is
unprecedented for a presidential nominee
in fact
if each lawsuit involving trump were the
basis of an episode of law and order
they could sustain all 456 episodes of
the original
or 389 episodes of law order svu
or 195 episodes of law and order
criminal intent and
all 22 episodes of law and order la
as well as every episode of the practice
ally mcbeal la law boston legal night
court the good wife
matlock jag perry mason judging amy the
guardian
the public defender owen marshall
counselor at law
harry's law courthouse suits family law
sweet justice 1971's the d.a 2004's the
d.a
reasonable doubts damages sharks the
defenders the paper chase head cases
judge for the defense and all three
episodes of nbc's first years
and at that point you're still missing
one lawsuit
but you've also basically run out of
television shows about lawyers
meaning trump's lawsuits exceed the
limits of the
genre well well lately
lately there have been some new
developments with trump-related
litigation after he complained about a
judge
presiding over two particular cases
against him i have a judge who is
a hater of donald trump a hater he's a
hater
his name is gonzalo curiel
and he is not doing the right thing
the judge who happens to be we believe
mexican which is great i think that's
fine
oh oh you do do you you think that's
great news people of mexican descent
donald trump thinks it's fine for you to
be a human being existing on this planet
now for the record the judge in question
was born in
indiana but that's not the point because
as he later clarified it was the judge's
mexican heritage that made him unfit
to judge trump you're invoking his race
when talking about whether or not he can
do his job
i'm building a wall okay i'm building a
wall i'm trying to keep business out of
mexico
mexico is fine there's nothing but he's
american american
he's a mexican heritage and he's very
proud of it as i am
where i come from wait where are you
where exactly are you from because you
look like you came out of a clogged
drain at the wonka factory
and you know what that's great i think
that's fine
but think about think about what he's
implying there the judge is unfit to do
his job because of his ethnic background
and just this morning trump took it a
step further
what if he was a muslim though you've
had been very tough on temporary muslim
immigration ban
if we're a muslim judge would you also
feel like they wouldn't be able to treat
you fair
fairly because of that policy of yours
uh it's possible yes
yeah that would be possible absolutely i
would say that was the dictionary
definition of bigotry except
after this campaign the definition of
bigotry might just become
c trump comma donald now
as it happens the judge he initially
insulted his overseeing cases involving
the controversial trump
university and he ordered a cache of
documents to be released
this week which was very exciting to us
because we actually looked
into his university when we did our big
piece on trump back in february
and it wound up on this very long list
of awful donald trump stories that we
literally didn't have time to delve into
even in a 22-minute piece but
once we started reading through these
new documents
we figured oh it let's take some
time to talk about it now
because trump university is kind of
amazing
back when it opened trump made some big
claims
at trump university we teach success
that's what it's all about
success it's going to happen to you if
you don't learn from the people that
we're going to be putting forward and
these are all people that are
hand-picked by me
then you're just not going to make it in
terms of the world of success
the world of success it sounds like what
donald trump
calls his bedroom welcome to the world
of success
please enjoy a mint and a non-disclosure
agreement
now unfortunately trump university ran
into problems in several states starting
with the name itself
we started looking at trump university
and uh
discovered that it was a classic bait
and switch scheme it was a
scam starting with the fact that it was
not a university
holy trump university wasn't even a
university
which is enough to make you wonder what
the was in trump's stakes
oh god it was possum wasn't it it was
possum you monsters
but the name was just the beginning
because remember how he had
hand-picked instructors well according
to his own depositions he did not
personally select instructors for live
seminars
and was unable to recall the names of
key faculty members
and it's probably good that he didn't
hand pick them himself that would be
dangerous
anything trump's tiny fingers touch turn
into an ex-wife or an abandoned casino
and and it doesn't stop there according
to the sworn testimony by several former
employees
many instructors and mentors had no
experience
buying or selling real estate in fact
one had worked as a salesman for lowe's
and another had been manager for buffalo
wild wings
or as i call it bdubs dubs and
even a former member of trump's own
sales staff testified that it was among
other things
a joke a facade and was just selling
false hopes and lies
and to be fair every university has sold
some of its students false hopes and
lies it's just most of the time
they call it a theater arts degree now
these these new documents also include
several revealing playbooks of sales
tactics for instance
the room temperature was to be no more
than 68 degrees which is partly to keep
students alert
and partly because professor wild wings
doesn't want the ranch source getting
all gamey
there are also instructors on how to
sell and upsell students
or as the playbooks call them buyers on
expensive courses with
typo riddle tips like if a client is
adamant about knowing the price
simply say our course range anywhere
from twenty nine dollars
to thirty five thousand dollars and if
prospects seemed at all wary there was
advice for dealing with that
you must be very aggressive one passage
from the playbook reads
if they complain about the price remind
them that
trump is the best you might laugh but
that is the same technique that trump
has been using to run for president and
apparently it works
these playbooks are rife with sleazy
salesmanship for instance employees were
told to substitute the words
thank you with congratulations so that
the potential customer ends up
thanking you which is pretty obnoxious
if i started this show every week with
welcome to last week tonight
congratulations on joining us you would
quite rightly turn it off
and i know what you're thinking well
what about people who simply didn't have
the money
trump you didn't really have a problem
with that
a set of playbooks for the sales team
coached them on how to market the
courses
even to single mothers with three
children who quote may need money for
food
money instructed the playbook is never a
reason for not enrolling in trump
university if they really believe in you
and your product they will find the
money
you are not doing any favor by letting
someone use lack of money
as an excuse lack of money is not an
excuse
is not what single parents need to hear
it's what donald trump needs to hear
when a fifth company of his inevitably
falls for chapter 11 bankruptcy
and as you might expect some of the
customers on the other end of that hard
sale wound up feeling duped like carmen
mendes
who put a 35 000 course on her credit
cards and was left disappointed
i thought that i'm going to be a
millionaire
because donald trump is a millionaire
and they were offering a course for
people to get
rich this is the closest mendez got to
trump during the course
a picture of her with a picture of
donald trump
oh that's not a one-off because another
former student said
we were told that we would get to have
our pictures taken with donald trump
it ended up being a cardboard cut out of
mr trump
which is actually a perfect metaphor for
trump university
you're expecting the real thing but in
the end all you get is a tacky
two-dimensional facade with donald
trump's face slapped on it
but perhaps the most suspicious thing of
all is that the playbooks even include
specific instructions on what to do if
an attorney general shows up
and believe it or not the answer is not
kick over a table as a distraction and
get the out of there
no apparently you contact april
immediately
and it also reminds you you do not have
to show them any personal information
unless they have a warrant
which is suspicious advice for a
university employee
i'm pretty sure harvard doesn't tell its
new professors welcome
here's a gun and a cyanide capsule in
case the first show up
don't let them take you alive
now donald trump donald trump
has broadly denied the claims in the
lawsuit and his attorneys have
gathered statements from satisfied
customers in fact to hear trump tell it
the school was very good value
98 of the people that took the courses
we have report cards from everybody
they report carded on the course 98
of the people that took the courses 98
approved the courses they thought they
were terrific
okay first there is something instantly
fishy about
98 the only things that have that level
of unanimous approval are
dictators pixar movies and neapolitan
ice cream
yeah it's got chocolate for the
chocoholics vanilla for the borings and
strawberry for the perverts
in fact according to plaintiffs the
reason
those numbers are so high is because the
surveys were not anonymous
and were filled out when participants
were still expecting to receive future
benefits from the program such as
assistance or mentoring from the
instructor they were evaluating
so listen to why one former student gave
it a good review that he now regrets
i really look at it like this is is say
you go to a really nice restaurant
and a really expensive restaurant you
eat this really gorgeous
dinner and the chef comes out near the
end of your meal and ask you how you
like the meal
and you really really loved it but then
you by the time you go home
you realize that you've gotten food
poisoning and you're really really sick
what do you think about trump university
i feel like i've been poisoned
i just feel like i was just duked and
poisoned and ripped off
the only thing worse than that is having
that same feeling and then realizing
oh he's got three years 364 days
left in his first term
but but perhaps the most valuable lesson
to come out of trump university is the
one that is currently giving
all of us in what's behind trump's
campaign strategy
because the playbook tells his sales
people you don't sell products benefits
or solutions
you sell feelings and that is what is
happening now
crowds at a trump rally may not be able
to point to a concrete benefit or
solution he offers
but they know how he makes them feel and
that is jacked up and ready to boo
any name that sounds vaguely latino
so if you are planning to vote for trump
in november i'd like to direct you to a
quote from the top
of trump university's old homepage take
the risk
but before you do learn what you're
getting yourself into
donald i could not have said it better
myself
so thank you or should i say
congratulations